Die nachricht war damals sensationell ein forschungsteam hat er vor zwei jahren
Verkündet spuren von flüssigem wasser auf dem mars gefunden zu haben ihr
indiz
Mysteriöse fliesst spuren in den krater hängen doch jetzt gibt es neue hinweise
Die das in frage stellen demnach sollen die fleece spuren wohl durch sand entstehen und eben nicht durch wasser zumindest ist sand
Beteiligt wie das forschungsteam aus arizona darauf kommt was die nasa dazu sagt und ob die chancen auf leben auf dem mars kleiner geworden sind
Jetzt in klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Wir haben hier ja schon öfter darüber berichtet wasser gilt als eine
Grundvoraussetzung für leben so wie wir es kennen verschiedene
forschungsteams weltweit fahnden fieberhaft nach indizien für wasser
Im weltraum wie zum beispiel auf dem mars denn dies würde zum einen die menschliche besiedlung des roten planeten
vereinfachen zum anderen wäre dies eine
grundlegende basis dafür dass auf dem mars rtn dieses leben entstehen könnte oder bereits entstanden ist die raumsonde mars reconnaissance orbiter
Lro
der nasa hat er vor einiger zeit
Messdaten angeliefert deren analyse bis jetzt als indizien für flüssiges wasser auf dem mars galten so hatte ein
Forschungsteam aus atlanta vor zwei jahren die these aufgestellt dass
Salziges schmelzwasser, im mass sommer wohl regelmäßig die steilhängen des roten planeten hindert fließe saisonal
auftretende fliesst strukturen an bestimmten abhängen
Sollten dies belegen diese dunklen finger artigen strukturen an steinen mars krater hängen werden. Ihre kühe ins lob linie kurz
rsl genannt, zudem hatte das forschungsteam damals spuren von salzen entlang der kraterwände entdeckt perchlorat
Die aus salzhaltigem wasser stammen könnten und sich innerhalb der abflussrinnen
abgelagert hätten das wasser selbst könnte vom eis abschmelzen dass sich unter dem mars boden befindet der
Damaligen vermutung nach könnte es dann an der oberfläche der kraterwände
Heraustreten und herr ablaufen diese these hat da was für jubel und wirklich große aufregung gesorgt als sie doch als fast
Eindeutiger beweis dafür dass auch heute noch wasser auf dem mars fließen könnte doch jetzt gibt es ernstzunehmende
zweifel an dieser these nach analysen eines forschungsteams
aus arizona stammen die damals entdeckten fliesst strukturen wohl eher von
abrutschenden sand sand und staub kölner sollen demnach zu den dunklen streifen
Abrutschen ihre these stützen sie auf ihre beobachtung dass die
beobachteten fliesst strukturen enden sobald die abhänge für sand zu flach werden zudem sei eine starke ähnlichkeit zu denjenigen
Rinnen, zu erkennen die sich hier auf der erde auf samt dünnen finden lassen das forschungsteam stützt sich dabei auf neue kamera aufnahmen der nasa
maßnahme insgesamt wurden 150 hänge an zehn orten untersucht das ergebnis die
mysteriösen jürgen klopp linie also kurz rsl fliesst struktur treten tatsächlich nur anhängen auf die steirer sind als 27 grad
dazu einer der beteiligten forscher alfred mcewen
zudem enden alle diese tricks strukturen auf böschungen die winkel aufweisen wie sie dem dynamischen verhalten von abrutschenden
Trockenen sand auf bühnen sowohl auf der erde als auch auf dem mars entsprechen eine struktur die vom vergleichsweise
größeren wassermengen verursacht wurde sollte sich hingegen über diese hinaus
ausbreiten diese übereinstimmung mit den merkmalen von abrutschenden trockenen sand können einfach kein zufall sein
Doch wirklich seriösen fliesst strukturen genau entstehen erklärt auch die aktuelle studie nicht wirklich und so schließt auch dieses forschungsergebnis nicht
Aus dass eventuell doch kleinste mengen an wasser auf dem mars vorhanden sein könnten dies würde auch die
ablagerungen der salze erklären die in bereits vorherigen studien als
Handfester hinweis für fließendes wasser galt auch die nasa hat sich zu dem aktuellen
forschungsergebnis geäußert sie bezieht sich eben auf die gefundenen salz spuren und auch auf das saisonale
auftreten der vlis strukturen beide entdeckungen könnten nicht alleine durch handbewegungen erklärt werden und die nase ergänzt
zudem die ergebnisse die in nature geoscience
veröffentlicht wurden sprechen dagegen dass genügend flüssiges wasser vorhanden ist dann
mit mikrobiellen leben an diesen standorten existieren kann es gibt zudem überlegungen
obwohl hinter diesen regierungslinie
Mechanismen stecken die uns noch unbekannt sind weil sie eventuell nur so auf dem mars geht bridge zurück von der nasa
Fast den status quo, so zusammen der neue bericht sagt das rsl nicht nass
Genug sind damit mobiles leben existieren könnte es sind untersuchungen vor ort mit speziellen verfahren
erforderlich dabei muss die einschleppung von mikroben von der erde verhindert werden denn noch immer fehlt eine
vollständige erklärung wie sich diese rätselhafte
Merkmale verdummt können und verblassen ja wenn ihr kein video zu möglichem leben auf dem mars und auch
zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann durch mir hier ein abo aufsaugen und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke denn nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue videos informiert hier geht es weiter mit dafür drauf klicken
Außer dieses leben auf dem mars neue indizien ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran